le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation il y en a
t'il en séance
ses membres à pois le procès verbal est
adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
mes chers collègues les conclusions
adoptées par la conférence des
présidents
qui s'est réuni hier sont consultables
sur le site du sénat en l'absence
d'observation je considère ces
conclusions comme adopté
madame la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et retransmise en direct
sur public sénat et sur notre site
internet
chacun d'entre vous sera attentif à
observer au cours de nos échanges à la
fois le respect du temps de parole et
non respect des uns et les autres je
donne la parole madame la présidente
eliane assassi pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes
avaient la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la première ministre
mes chers collègues l'évidence est là
l'inflation galope jusqu'à 7% d'ici la
fin de l'année tandis que le pouvoir
d'achat des français recule de 2,9 pour
cent sur les premiers trimestres
l'évidence c'est que les français les
moins aisés souffre bientôt ce n'est
plus de pouvoir d'achat qu'il faudra
parler mais de pouvoir de vivre
l'évidence c'est qu'en 2021 les
entreprises du cac 40 ont réalisé 174
milliards d'euros de bénéfices explosant
le record de 2007 200 milliards 80
milliards de dividendes ont été reversés
aux actionnaires ces gens qui profite du
travail des autres et les salaires des
patrons ont augmenté de 23%
l'occasion d'une petite valse du en même
temps emmanuel macron dénoncé au dernier
g7 les profiteurs de guerre et les
spéculateurs mais temporise et dès le 14
juillet il y aurait une contribution
certes mais pas dans la démagogie vous
même madame la première ministre
adoptiez l'art du contretemps s'il y a
des gens qui tirent des profits de la
crise on souhaiterait que ça puisse
bénéficier à le monde et vous précisiez
que nous n'étions pas dans la situation
de nos voisins qui ont instauré une taxe
sur les super-profits super profits le
mot est lâché dans le domaine
énergétique et du transport maritime en
particulier total plus de 15 milliards
en 2000 21 5 milliards au premier
trimestre 2010 22 la cma-cgm a vu son
bénéfice multiplié par dix en 2021 nous
ne leur demandons pas une aumône de 20
centimes ou une remise de 250 euros par
transport de conteneurs nous exigeons
une contribution par l'impôt qui pour
autant qu'ils soient justes est un
pilier de la république ce n'est pas au
conseil d'administration de décider de
la participation des entreprises à
l'effort national mais au parlement en
l'inscrivant dans la loi en toute
transparence c'est une question de
démocratie
madame la première ministre gouvernement
va qu'il déposait dans le projet de loi
de finances rectificative un amendement
pour taxer les super profits ou à minima
soutenir les amendements parlementaires
y compris de vos amis qui vont aussi en
ce sens
pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame la première
ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
présidente à sacy tout d'abord nous
avons appris nous venons d'apprendre le
décès d'un adjudant chef engagé dans la
lutte contre un feu de forêt à tarascon
je voudrais lui rendre hommage adresser
toutes mes condoléances à sa famille et
à ses proches et saluer une nouvelle
fois l'engagement de nos pompiers
militaires forces de l'ordre agents des
collectivités qui sont nos héros du
quotidien peut-être je vous propose de
leur rendre hommage
alors il ya une chose sur laquelle nous
pouvons nous accorder madame la
présidente
il serait choquant alors que l'inflation
est forte que certaines entreprises
accentuent leur profit et ne contribue
pas à aider les français
cette conviction je les partager avec
vous dans ma déclaration de politique
générale c'est celle de mon gouvernement
et c'est celle que le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire a fait valoir
devant les entreprises concernées car
madame la présidente notre priorité
c'est bien de protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des français c'est pourquoi
plutôt que de laisser filer les profits
et de les taxer ensuite sans effets
directs pour nos concitoyens nous avons
préféré mettre les entreprises face à
leurs responsabilités et obtenir des
résultats concrets
c'est ainsi que total annoncé total
energy a annoncé une remise de 20
centimes sur les carburants c'est ainsi
que nous avons obtenu de cma-cgm une
baisse des prix du transport des
containers ce sont des mesures concrètes
pour le pouvoir d'achat des français
et je crois aussi qu un engagement dans
la durée est préférable à une taxation
ponctuelles c'est le sens des mesures
que nous vous proposons dans les textes
sur le pouvoir d'achat nous permettons
en particulier aux entreprises
d'accompagner leurs salariés face à la
hausse des prix du carburant en doublant
le plafond de la prime transport nous
attendons également des entreprises
qu'elles soutiennent les revenus de
leurs salariés notamment en se
saisissant de la prime de partage de la
valeur et des dispositifs
d'intéressement et de participation
et puis de plus nous demandons à toutes
les branches dont les minima sont
inférieurs au smic qu'elle ouvre sans
délai des négociations pour revaloriser
leur grille et madame la présidente je
veux le dire également nous serons
attentifs à ce que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités et nous serons prêts à
agir s'il le faut dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finances pour 2023 jour
merci
je vais donner maintenant la parole au
président françois patriat pour le
groupe du rassemblement des démocrates
progrès social et vous avez la parole
ce présent merci mesdames messieurs mes
chers collègues madame la première
ministre ma question s'adresse à vous et
elle concerne l'organisation des jeux
olympiques
dans deux ans dans deux ans notre pays
accueillera pour la première fois depuis
100 ans et pour la première fois les
jeux olympiques paralympiques à paris
nous sommes convaincus que notre pays
sera en capacité d'organiser ce grand
événement international
ce dernier doit être pour chaque
français et pour chaque français un
moment de fierté nous savons que les
retombées de ces jeux sont immenses les
attentes sont donc légitimes ou si forte
en métropole que dans les outre mer à
l'issue du conseil olympique et
paralympique
le chef de l'état a eu raison d'exiger
que tout soit mis en oeuvre pour
répondre à cette ambition nous savons
tous qu'elle est très grande parce que
le gouvernement organise encore de la
même importance aux jeux olympiques et
paralympiques
il y aura deux cérémonies d'ouverture
oui mes chers collègues deux cérémonies
d'ouverture que le rga liseron pour la
première fois en dehors des stades aussi
les français s'interrogent a raison sur
la sécurité et sur la quiétude de ces
événements ils attendent également que
contrairement aux éditions précédentes
et budget soit respectée dans celui du
comité d'organisation des jeux que de
l'établissement public qui assure la
construction des sites en dehors bien
entendu des effets de l'inflation dont
personne ici ne pouvait prévoir
l'intensité il ya quelques mois encore
il espère enfin que nous aurons faire de
cet événement un levier pour favoriser
la pratique sportive au quotidien dont
toutes les études démontrent les impacts
positifs sur la santé notamment pour
ceux qui en sont aujourd'hui trop
éloignés alors ma dame la première
ministre la question est double comment
le gouvernement entend t-il garantir la
sécurité des jeux et la qualité des
équipements tout en assurant de faire
vivre ces jeux à tous les françaises et
à tous les français je vous remercie
vous répondre la parole et madame madame
la première ministre avait la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président patriat alors effectivement
les jeux olympiques et paralympiques
sont un événement exceptionnel pour
notre pays et c'est le monde entier qui
regardera la france et je peux vous
l'assurer l'ensemble de mon gouvernement
est mobilisé sur le sujet la réunion qui
s'est tenue lundi autour du président de
la république nous a permis de
réaffirmer nos ambitions et d'accélérer
nous avons fait un bilan d'étape et
identifier des points de vigilance alors
la sécurité d'abord vous l'avez évoqué
sous la responsabilité du ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin les jeux
mobiliseront chaque jour entre 7000 et
onze mille membres des forces de
sécurité intérieure à leurs côtés
interviendront des militaires dont les
missions seront précisées en lien avec
le ministre des armées ainsi que des
agents de sécurité privée privée en lien
avec olivier du soft nous allons
intensifier la mobilisation et les
formations dans ce secteur où il ya
encore trop d'emplois non pourvus
notre deuxième point d'attention c'est
le budget des jeux pour le budget du
comité d'organisation la ligne est
simple et le président de la république
l'a rappelé les jeux finance les jeux
nous serons vigilants à ce que paris
2024 qui est financé à 98% par des
recettes privées respecte bien ce cadre
troisième point la mobilité nous
veillerons avec les collectivités à
garantir les bons déplacements pour les
athlètes et les spectateurs tout en
minimisant l'impact sur le quotidien des
franciliens et puis monsieur le
président vous avez raison de le
rappeler ces jeux doivent être ceux de
tous les français il doit elle devait
être porteur d'un héritage fort pour
notre pays pour les territoires qui
accueille les jeux notamment la seine
saint denis et puis je n'oublie pas
l'inclusion et la pratique sportive des
personnes en situation de handicap avec
les jeux paralympiques la ministre des
sports amélie oudéa castéra est
totalement mobilisé sur ces sujets donc
vous l'avez vu le président de la
république a annoncé que l'état
distribuerait quatre cent mille billets
notamment pour les plus jeunes sur
l'héritage plusieurs mesures ont été
annoncées hier notamment le renforcement
du sport à l'école au collège et dans le
monde professionnel ou encore la
décision de faire de la pratique
sportive la grande cause nationale pour
2024 donc monsieur le président soyez
assurés de la pleine mobilisation de
chacun des membres de mon gouvernement
mais par ailleurs les collectivités sont
aussi au coeur de la réussite des jeux
nous voulons naturellement les associer
pleinement aussi une réunion se tiendra
à la rentrée avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes en premier lieu les
collectivités qui sont principalement
concernées par ces jeux je remercie
monsieur patriat
david assouline pour le groupe
socialiste
écologistes et républicains donner la
parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
première ministre à l'heure de l'hyper
concentration des médias privés et de la
concurrence sauvage des grandes
plateformes américaines au lieu de
renforcer notre service public de
l'audiovisuel pour faire face vous avez
décidé de l'affaiblir structurellement
et de remettre en cause son indépendance
en supprimant la redevance en bricolant
un financement non pérennes et payée par
tous les français les plus pauvres une
part fléchés de la tva que vous enlevez
à d'autres services et fléchage qui ne
sera plus possible dès 2025 ma question
est précise quels sont les services aux
français qui seront amputés de ses 3,7
milliards de tva et comment
l'audiovisuel public serait financée à
partir de 2025
pour vous répondre la parole et ministre
délégué en charge du renouveau
démocratique porte parole du
gouvernement monsieur verrons merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je vais
commencer par cité des grands auteurs
qui sont les excellents sénateurs
karoutchi et hugonnet qui ont rendu un
rapport sur la question de la redevance
audiovisuelle il ya peu qui parlait d'un
système à bout de souffle qui n'étaient
pas justes et qui ne permettait plus de
garantir la pérennité du financement de
l'audiovisuel or vous dire vous avez
avec nous des points communs je connais
votre engagement monsieur le sénateur à
souligner sur cette question en
particulier d'abord l'engagement du
pouvoir d'achat pour les français et
ensuite l'engagement d'avoir un service
audiovisuel public indépendant fort et
bien financé le rapport d'inspection
générale qui a été d'ailleurs fourni aux
sénateurs atteste que chaque année
l'état devait compléter à hauteur de 600
millions d'euros le financement lié à la
seule redevance audiovisuelle parce que
ça ne suffisait plus et donc nous avons
le gouvernement a présenté un projet de
suppression de cet impôt donc c'est
effectivement du pouvoir d'achat en plus
pour les français il n'y a pas de
d'impôt cacher derrière il n'y a pas de
taxe cachée pour vous en convaincre
regardez le bilan du principe du
précédent quinquennat ou les
gouvernements des manuels macron
successifs ont réduit les impôts de 26
milliards d'euros pour les français donc
ils savent que c'est possible et nous
continuerons à le faire et les
parlementaires dans le cadre du débat
ont proposé un dispositif qui est
effectivement une part de la tva qui
serait affecté à l'euro l'euro vers le
service d'audiovisuel public jusqu'en
2025 en 2025 monsieur le sénateur il
reste tout à fait possible si la
représentation nationale ont décidé de
continuer de flécher des segments
entiers de fiscalité vers les dépenses
particulières donc n'ayez aucune crainte
sur la volonté du gouvernement et la
volonté des parlementaires je le dis des
rangs des oppositions et de la majorité
à l'assemblée nationale et demain
peut-être des rangs de la majorité et
des oppositions au sénat nous le
souhaitons pour un garantir le
financement pérenne à hauteur de
l'audiovisuel public et de restituer du
pouvoir d'achat aux français
monsieur assouline
vous ne me répondez pas et c'est l'aveu
de votre improvisation à l'heure du
danger populiste
je suis tellement désolée de vos propos
démagogiques qui cherchent à opposer de
façon malsaine la légitime aspiration de
pouvoir d'achat des français à la
liberté d'informer à la création à la
culture dont on a tant besoin pour vivre
ne voyez vous pas qu'en cassant cette
digue vous pavé le chemin de ceux qui
voudront privatiser ce service public
comme marine le pen nous demandant
depuis longtemps une modernisation de la
redevance pendant cinq ans vous n'avez
rien fait alors que nos voisins non
réformé sans jamais la supprimer nous
voulons qu'elle soit plus juste et
proportionnel vous proposer un
financement par l'impôt le plus injuste
que la tva nous voulons qu'elle soit
pérenne et vous proposer un financement
dans la fin est formellement programmé
en 2025 si vous étiez ouvert vous
retiriez cette proposition et nous
pourrions avoir un travail commun pour
réformer ensemble dès le budget 2011 23
à l'automne en attendant nous voterons
contre
et si votre suppression était adoptée
nous saisirons le conseil
constitutionnel car c'est notre sénat en
2008 à notre initiative qui avait fait
inscrire dans la constitution à
l'article 34 la liberté l'indépendance
et le pluralisme des médias
mais aussi
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
l'aironi guillotin pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je souhaite vous alerter
aujourd'hui sur l'une des préoccupations
majeures des élus et des familles pour
la rentrée il s'agit bien de la
difficulté à recruter dans les
transports scolaires selon les
transporteurs il manquerait 8000
conducteur pour le ramassage scolaire
qui affecterait potentiellement près de
quatre cent mille élèves et familles et
ceci dès le mois de septembre comme dans
beaucoup d'autres métiers difficiles et
mal payé la désaffection ne date pas
d'hier effectivement la baisse des
vocations a été entamée il ya plusieurs
années maintenant et s'est aggravée avec
la pandémie au faible rémunération aux
horaires décalés morcelé est venue
s'ajouter la fermeture des
établissements scolaires pendant la
crise qu vide ceci a poussé un grand
nombre de personnes à se retourner ou à
se tourner vers des transports routiers
de marchandises ou à changer totalement
de métier des métiers moins exigeant la
tendance s'observe chez toutes les
catégories de personnel encadrant les
enfants sur le temps scolaire le temps
périscolaire les centres loisirs mais
également les crèches au delà des
difficultés propres à chaque métier se
pose deux questions celle de la
valorisation de ces personnels qui nous
sont absolument indispensables et enfin
celle du soutien aux élus locaux qui se
démène comme ils peuvent pour offrir à
nos enfants un accueil approprié ces
deux questions ne trouveront pas de
réponse nous trouveront des réponses que
si des mesures d'ampleur sont mises sur
la table or en matière de mesures
d'ampleur vous admettrez que c'est bien
l'état qui a la main certes les régions
s'investissent dans grand s le conseil
régional et les rectorats prévoit par
exemple d'étaler les horaires de début
et de sortie des cours des collèges et
des lycées dans six départements pour
qu'un même chauffeur plus faire
plusieurs rotations mais vous
comprendrez bien que cette solution
n'est que de court terme aussi pouvez
vous monsieur le ministre a précisé les
mesures qui sont envisagées par le
gouvernement pour assurer aux familles
et aux élus un ramassage scolaire digne
de ce nom dès la rentrée pour vous
répondre la parole et co maëlys du
travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion monsieur diop vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vous nous interroger sur les
risques en matière de recrutement de
chauffeurs de transports scolaires pour
la rentrée je voudrais d'abord vous dire
que c'est une priorité du gouvernement
pas seulement du ministère du travail du
ministère l'éducation nationale les
ministères des collectivités
territoriales et du ministère des
transports de tout mettre en oeuvre dans
un délai court pour apporter des
solutions et permettre la meilleure
qualité de transport scolaire à la
rentrée cela passe par des initiatives
locales vous les avez rappelé pour
permettre un même chauffeur de faire
plusieurs circuits plusieurs tournées de
ramassage scolaire cela passe par hommes
la mobilisation du service public de
l'emploi pour recruter former et
sensibiliser sur ce métier mais aussi
lui redonner de l'attractivité ça passe
aussi par des formations et l'état dans
le cadre du plan de réduction des
tensions de recrutement se tient prêt
aussi à financer un peu plus long terme
évidemment des formations pour permettre
à des chauffeurs dont nous savons que
bien souvent leurs postes sont à temps
partiel vous l'avez dit est soulignée
dans votre question leur part est d
exercer des activités complémentaires et
ainsi trouver une possibilité de
développement professionnel que la seule
profession des chauffeurs de ramassage
scolaire de transport scolaire ne leur
permettrait pas les préfets sont
mobilisés les recteurs sont mobilisés je
le répète avec mes trois collègues c'est
un travail de chaque instant pour
apporter des réponses votre question sur
les chauffeurs de transport scolaire
souligne les difficultés de recrutement
d'un grand nombre de secteurs d'activité
depuis octobre 2021 nous avons mis en
place un plan de réduction des tensions
ce sont 1,4 milliard d'euros qui sont
mobilisés pour à la fois former des
salariés dans les entreprises afin
qu'ils puissent acquérir des compétences
utiles au développement de l'entreprise
et aussi pour former des demandeurs
d'emploi cela a permis de répondre à
plus d'un million d'offres d'emploi par
pôle emploi cela a permis le retour à
l'emploi de 240 mille chômeurs de longue
durée cela permet aussi de réorienter
d'amener vers des secteurs qui
aujourd'hui souffrent en matière
d'attractivité des hommes et des femmes
qui connaissent la une deuxième carrière
grâce à des formations et grâce à
l'investissement du service public de
l'emploi le secteur du transport
scolaire est un des exemples et c'est un
exemple d'actualité puisque dans
quelques semaines la rentrée scolaire
devra être préparé mais je peux vous
garantir à la fois la mobilisation je
les dis mais aussi la mise en oeuvre de
moyens de formation et le financement de
mayenne formation apporter des réponses
plus pérenne madame
quelques secondes
mais merci monsieur le ministre pour les
réponses ce que je voulais dire c'est
bien évidemment qu'à travers le
transport scolaire c'est de l'éducation
générale de nos enfants dont nous
parlons est que c'est un sujet majeur et
j'espère qu effectivement des solutions
seront trouvées parce que dès le mois de
septembre on ne peut pas laisser et les
élus et les familles dans telles
difficultés
merci vous donner la parole notre
collègue mélanie vogel pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoires la
parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ma question porte vous vous en
doutez sur la gestion de l'épidémie de
la variole simienne je sais que le
gouvernement s'est déjà fait cuisiner
hier à l'assemblée et si je vous repose
la question aujourd'hui c'est pas pour
vous embêter c'est pas parce que j'adore
la répétition mais c'est parce qu'en
fait on n'a toujours pas la réponse vous
nous répéter en gros que tout va bien on
ne vous dit pas combien de vaccins
secret défense mais croyez-nous on en a
assez en fait vous pouvez nous dire tout
ce que vous voulez mais la réalité c'est
qu'il ya aujourd'hui en france des
milliers de personnes qui savent
qu'elles doivent se faire vacciner
devrait faire vacciner essaie de se
faire vacciner et ne sont pas vaccinés
parce que juste elles ne peuvent pas et
je parle même pas de toutes les
personnes qui devraient se faire
vacciner mais qui sont même pas au
courant parfois de l'information donc
pardon mais en fait cette situation elle
est incompréhensible quand on vient de
gérer une épidémie qu'on à vacciner des
dizaines de millions de personnes en
france qu'on a des chemins logistique
qui existent qui permettent d'acheminer
des vaccins en masse conséquente dans
une épidémie chaque jour compte l'année
dernière j'ai regardé le 27 juillet 2021
on a vacciné en france 650 7403
personnes contre le coc vide en un jour
un jour c'est plus que l'ensemble des
personnes à risque qui doivent être
vaccinés contre la variole simienne en
france donc c'est incompréhensible et
moi les choses incompréhensibles ça
m'énerve donc j'essaie de comprendre
donc ma question c'est quoi en fait vos
chiffres moi j'ai regardé en gros il ya
plus de cinq cent mille utilisateurs de
grinder en france plus ces travailleurs
et travailleuses du sexe plus les
professionnels de santé il faut deux
doses donc en gros à la louche il nous
faut entre six cents mille un million
deux on n'a pas des stocker 5 % de ça
est ce qu'aujourd'hui sans nous dire
combien vous avez en totale en stock
mais est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on a entre
600 mille et un million de doses en
france si oui pourquoi ça bloque sinon
quand est ce qu'on peut en avoir assez
et combien ça coûte et est ce que c'est
ça le problème est ce qu'en fait
dépenser plein d'argent pour ces gens là
qui pour l'instant s'infecte entre eux
ça vous ennuie un peu
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
monsieur françois braun
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice vogel
ma détermination n'ayez aucun doute pour
protéger les français total et je veux
être très clair
toute personne souhaitant être vaccinés
contre la variole du singe le sera
face à cette affection nous agissons
activement nous rappelons les gestes de
prévention nous déployons la vaccination
qui est une solution complémentaire à la
prévention
la france a été l'un des premiers pays à
ouvrir la vaccination préventive
dès que l'avis de la has a été publiée
la haute autorité de santé je rappelle
que celle ci est gratuite
plus de 110 centres de vaccination
étaient ouverts en seulement quelques
jours sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
cela nous a permis aujourd'hui de
vacciner 7400 personnes dans des points
contact connu facilement identifiés
comme les gels et c'est dit les cj de
pardon la france est l'un des pays du
monde dans lequel le plus grand nombre
de vaccinations a été réalisée
nous continuons notre montée en
puissance nous venons d'ouvrir aux
étudiants en santé la possibilité de
renforcer les équipes de vaccination
pour faciliter l'accès au rendez vous
par ailleurs un grand centre de
vaccination étaient ouverts hier dans le
xiiie arrondissement de paris l'île de
france étant la région la plus touchée
vous le savez le nombre de vaccin contre
la variole est une donnée nationale
classée secret défense la variole peut
effectivement être utilisé comme arme
biologique de guerre c'est pour cela que
nous ne reviendrons pas et que je ne
peux pas communiquer sur le nombre de
doses global toutefois je veux rassurer
les français quarante deux mille doses
ont été à ce jour déstocker les stocks
seront libérées au fil de l'eau de
nouvelles commandes de vaccin contre la
variole on était passé tout récemment
auprès du seul laboratoire qui produit
aujourd'hui ce vaccin de troisième
génération il faut effectivement
continuer à renouveler les stocks enfin
même si la variole du singe ce
diagnostic le plus souvent est très
généralement par un examen clinique il
arrive qu'un test biologique soit
nécessaire pour compléter le diagnostic
un arrêté sera publié d'ici la fin de
semaine il permettra une prise en charge
de ce test par l'assurance maladie comme
le recommande la has la haute autorité
de santé je veux profiter de ce propos
pour rappeler sans cesse que ma
détermination avec ma collègue elisabeth
rome est totale en matière de lutte
contre les discours de haine et nous
travaillons en étroite collaboration
avec les associations depuis le début
notamment pour communiquer les messages
de prévention
merci la parole et comme leurs collègues
vanina paolig agen pour le groupe les
indépendants
monsieur le président madame la ministre
en france chaque village à son église
chaque église ses vitraux ses créations
qui datent souvent de plusieurs siècles
illumine le patrimoine de tous nos
territoires c'est particulièrement vrai
dans l'aube où l'on compte la plus
grande concentration nationale de
vitraux avec 9000 m² de verrières
réparties dans 200 édifice au petit
admirer toute l'évolution de cet art du
12e siècle à nos jours les maîtres
verriers sont les dépositaires de ces
savoir-faire pluriséculaire ils les font
vivre par la restauration des vitraux
mais aussi par des créations nouvelles
qui excède largement le cadre religieux
or pour continuer à faire vivre ses
savoir-faire de restauration et de
création les vitres à istres recours
depuis toujours au plomb cette substance
dont la toxicité est avérée est intégré
à leurs pratiques il s'en protège via
les deux pays mais la médecine du
travail doit assurer un meilleur suivi
car malheureusement ils ne disposent pas
d'alternative à cette substance
aujourd'hui ces savoir-faire madame la
ministre on me ac par la révision du
règlement européen reach qui encadre
l'utilisation des substances chimiques
et prévoit tout simplement
l'interdiction du plomb c'est bien
simple mes chers collègues si le plomb
est interdit les vitrailliste ne
pourront plus exercer leur activité pour
prendre un exemple concret qui parle à
chacun d'entre nous sans plomb
impossible de restaurer à l'identique
les vitraux de notre dame de paris j'ai
déposé une proposition de résolution
européenne pour défendre cette exemption
de droit et sans frais pour tous les
vitrailliste le sénat l'a adopté je
tiens à remercier les deux rapporteurs
qui ont planché sur ce texte mes
collègues catherine morin desailly et
louis jean de nicolay ils ont montré que
d'autres métiers d'art tels les facteurs
d'orgue est également menacée par cette
interdiction madame la ministre ma
question est simple défendre et vous au
niveau européen une exemption à titre
gracieux pour ces métiers d'art la
chambre des territoires vous le demande
il en va de la préservation et de la
valorisation de notre patrimoine
exceptionnel je vous remercie
bon vous répondre la parole est à madame
la secrétaire d'état en charge de
l'europe madame laurence boone
monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
madame la sénatrice paoli gagnant
d'abord votre question me donne
l'occasion de vous remercier pour le
travail réalisé depuis plusieurs
semaines sur cet enjeu qui est important
le travail que vous avez réalisé avec
votre proposition de résolution
européenne
adopté par la commission des affaires
européennes du sénat la semaine dernière
et dont j'ai évidemment pris
connaissance vous l'avez dit l'aube et
en particulier la ville de troyes est le
berceau de l'art du vitrail et je crois
que tous ici nous connaissons votre
engagement sur ce sujet essentiel
puisqu'il préoccupe nos entreprises du
vitrail des monuments historiques et de
manière générale c'est l'ensemble du
tissu du patrimoine français
et donc avec macaulay grimaldo mme malak
nous sommes particulièrement attentive
aux consultations et discussions qui
sont menées au niveau européen primable
humala comme vous le savez ne peut
malheureusement pas être avec nous
aujourd'hui puisqu'elle accompagne
résidant dans son voyage au bénin
une consultation publique a été ouverte
elle va durer du 2 février
un pardon à la durée du 2 février au 22
mai au 2 mai 2022 par l' agence
européenne des produits chimiques sur le
projet de recommandation de substances
prioritaires pour leur inclusion dans la
liste des substances qui seront soumises
à autorisation du règlement européen
reach je souligne que celui ci ne
prévoit pas l'interdiction mais il
propose de soumettre le plomb à
autorisation est le résultat de la
consultation n'est pas encore connue
donc le comité des états membres qui
s'appelle comité reach devra se
prononcer sur le tonnage sur la
dangerosité et le caractère dispersif et
l'examinent évidemment l'impact sur
l'industrie
vous nous vous nous l'avez demandé le
gouvernement entend évidemment la voix
du sénat sur ce sujet et je peux vous
assurer de notre pleine mobilisation
auprès de la commission européenne pour
garantir que toute évolution de la
réglementation en la matière permettent
de préserver l'ensemble du secteur du
vitrail des monuments historiques et du
patrimoine culturel merci madame
la parole et à d'autres collègues
mathieu darnaud pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le ministre des
régions aux communes en passant par les
départements les élus de nos
collectivités pousse un cri d' alerte
ils s'inquiètent de savoir comment ils
vont faire face à l'augmentation
du coût des énergies à la revalorisation
de trois et demi pour cent du point
d'indicé dans la fonction publique ou
encore à cette inflation galopante et
face à cela la réponse du gouvernement
est quelque peu déconcertante ici même
le 7 juillet lors d'une réunion de la
commission des finances votre éminent
collègue bruno le maire a affirmé qu'il
fallait faire une ponction de 10
milliards d'euros de haut niveau de la
dgf annonce aussitôt contredite par vous
même monsieur le ministre en disant
qu'il fallait je cite des branches et ce
chiffre et puis matignon s'est invité
dans le débat en nous disant qu'il
fallait mieux une baisse des dépenses
plutôt que plus tôt par dont une
limitation de la rose plutôt qu'une
baisse des dépenses et enfin nous avons
reçu par parfaitement tardivement le
programme de stabilité qui nous invite à
réduire de 0,5 pour cent les dépenses de
fonctionnement en volumes de l'ensemble
de nos collectivités vous comprendrez
alors le désarroi des élus de l'ensemble
de nos collectivités et je pense qu'il y
avait ri ta ble ment monsieur le
ministre une urgence territoriales ma
question est très simple elle appelle de
la clarté de votre part comment comptez
vous répondre à cette urgence
territoriales
[Applaudissements]
or vont répandre la parole et organiste
de la transition écologique de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur béchu
monsieur le président madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
merci pour votre question
parce que le flou se nourrit des
silences et les couacs sont parfois
surinterpréter quand on juxtapose un
certain nombre de déclarations je n'ai
aucun doute sur le fait que vous ne
cherchez rien d'autre que d'apaiser les
inquiétudes légitimes des élus locaux
qui comme les ménages s'interroge dans
un contexte d'inflation forte et se
retrouve globalement avec une équation
qui est simple on a des dépenses qui
augmentent on est collectivement ici
hostile à l'augmentation des impôts et
nous pensons dans le même temps que le
sujet de la dépense publique est un
sujet sérieux
il y a deux calendriers qui
s'entremêlent c'est d'abord le paix
stable c'est à dire la nécessité pour la
fin du mois de juillet de transmettre
pour cinq ans la totalité des éléments
qui vont composer la stratégie
financière et qui correspond pour le
coup est ce que vous souhaitez montrer
on va revenir dans les clous d'une
dépense publique plus maîtrisé en fin de
période il ya ensuite un certain
d'interprétation qu'on peut faire et
dont je veux tout de suite clarifier les
choses il n'y aura pas de baisses de
dotations des collectivités locales
nous ne revenons pas à la période où on
fait des ponctions dgf ça n'est ni prévu
dans le plf dit dans aucun document ni
dans le paix stable il n'y aura pas il
n'y aura pas de retour des contrats de
cahors le contexte d'inflation que nous
connaissons ne s'y prête pas il y a même
dans le paix stable dans les prévisions
une progression des dépenses des
collectivités locales qui est anticipée
à hauteur de 24 milliards d'euros sur la
période alors de quoi s'agit-il de
quelque chose que votre groupe appelle
de ses voeux depuis longtemps une
modération de la dépense publique cette
modération de la dépense publique ça
consiste pas à baisser les dépenses ça
consiste pas à diminuer les dotations ça
consiste à faire en sorte qu'on
réussisse à faire un peu mieux que
l'inflation en tendance comment on fait
avec des subventions d'investissement
pour que les collectivités puissent
investir dans la une trajectoire de
transition écologique qui permettent
précisément de diminuer les factures de
chauffage d'améliorer l'isolation et de
tenir à la fois une tragique or carbone
et une trajectoire des finances
publiques
monsieur d'arnaud
oui monsieur le ministre le flou se
nourrit aussi de ce qu'on ne dit pas et
en l'occurrence vous avez dit ce que
vous ne ferez pas mais vous avez surtout
pas dit ce que vous comptez faire et
surtout vous n'avez avancer aucun
chiffre j'ai noté quand même qu'il y
aurait quand une ponction vous l'avez
dit de la dgf ce qui ne va pas empêcher
de nourrir un certain un certain
ambiguïté chez les élus locaux en tout
cas dans votre réponse il n'ya
véritablement pas de quoi rassurer les
élus des territoires
[Applaudissements]
la parole était notre collègue sonia de
la provôté pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre de la
santé monsieur le ministre sa direction
de l'évaluation statistique du ministère
a publié son rapport annuel sur la
situation des établissements de santé en
2020 ce qu'il révèle laisse plutôt
songeur entre 2013 et 2020 ce sont dix
neuf mille lits qui ont été supprimés
dans l'hôpital public
plus problématique encore ces fermetures
se sont accélérées en 2020 en pleine
crise qu vide au total cinq mille 700
lits ont été fermés en 2020 soit une
baisse de 1 2% par rapport à 2010 9
alors que la baisse était jusque là en
moyenne de 0 9% par an rien ne
justifiait une telle accélération
aussi insensé si ce n'est un virage net
vers l'ambulatoire et la perpétuation
des mesures budgétaires prises bien
avant la crise l'hôpital s'est recentré
sur sa vocation d'urgence la pandémie
entraîné une hausse significative des
capacités en soins critiques pour le
reste on compte sur la ville sans
s'assurer que la prise en charge soit
possible c'est nier que l'activité
hospitalière déborde largement le cadre
de l'urgence en parallèle
malheureusement les capacités
ambulatoire elle ne semble pas adaptée à
due proportion
monsieur le ministre la fermeture de
lits ouvre un cercle vicieux de pénurie
du personnel moins de lits c'est moins
de personnel et moins de personnel
entraîne la fermeture de nouveaux lits
dans ces conditions le virage vers
l'ambulatoire ne peut s'analyser que
comme une mesure financière et non une
politique sanitaire monsieur le ministre
à rebours des différents plomb encore en
cours allez vous stoppez les fermetures
définitives de lits à l'hôpital en
mettant temps-ci enfin la fin à cette
finale cette spirale infernale
je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
monsieur françois brome je suis ministre
j'avais la parole
sur le président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice de la provôté vous appuyez sur
le panorama des établissements de santé
de la drees sorti hier et qui fait état
d'une baisse du nombre de lits en
hospitalisation complète pour l'année
2020 c'est l'objet d'ailleurs de ce
rapport il faut et c'est le médecin qui
connaît un peu voir bien l'hôpital qui
parle replacer ce chiffre dans son
contexte le nombre de lits
d'hospitalisation complète ne permet pas
loin de là à lui seul d'apprécier la
capacité du système de soins à prendre
en charge les besoins de la population
en effet avec l'amélioration des
technologies des traitements médicaux
des techniques chirurgicales
il est possible de prendre en charge de
plus en plus de patients sans nuit à
l'hôpital ou directement à domicile de
réduire les durées de séjour au bénéfice
des patients toujours en premier lieu
cela correspond d'ailleurs à une
aspiration forte de nos concitoyens de
plus durant la crise qu vide nous avons
dû procéder à des réorganisations et
vite pour éviter la contagion des
chambres à deux lits des chambres
doubles ont dû être transformés en
chambres simples réduisant de fait le
nombre de lits délit nombreux ont été
ouverts en soins critiques pour cela il
a fallu aller chercher du personnel
provenant d'autres services qui a été
réaffecté ce qui a contribué là aussi à
une baisse totale du nombre de lits dans
la mesure où les prises en charge en
soins critiques demande plus de
personnel autour des patients pour
autant et vous le savez je ne néglige
pas loin de là les difficultés que
connaît l'hôpital dans notre pays je
veux m'attaquer à une refonte en
profondeur de notre système de santé en
passant justement d'un système fondé sur
l'offre de soins
le nombre lee vers un système basé sur
la réponse aux besoins de santé de la
population ce sera notamment l'objet de
la concertation des parties prenantes
qui doit nous permettre de trouver des
solutions pragmatiques
applicable sur le terrain en fonction
des besoins identifiés de chaque
territoire
je veux aussi je m'appuierai bien sûr
sur le travail des parlementaires je
suis à votre disposition pour cela
ob de la provoquer
monsieur le ministre c'est le médecin
aussi qui vous répond comme le rapport
récent du sénat de nos collègues
catherine de roche et berlin joue à miel
à démontrer l'hôpital public est un
maillon essentiel de la chaîne sanitaire
avec moins de lits moins de personnel de
soin il est démuni et la santé tous de
tous affaibli comme la médecine de ville
comme les hôpitaux non publique il est
au service de la santé et non du budget
arbitrer c'est choisir et choisir s'est
renforcée chacun de ses maillons le
pragmatisme a un coût choisir c'est
moins de contraintes plus d'humains plus
de solidarité solidarité et c'est
surtout un lieu de soin
merci
la parole est à notre collègue valérie
boyer pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre il y a une semaine parce qu'ils
ont tenté d'interpeller un homme ayant
commis un vol à l'arraché trois
policiers en civil ont été violemment
attaqués à lyon à la guillotière au nom
des républicains je veux leur dire mon
total soutien et pourtant selon le garde
des sceaux la france n'est pas un coupe
gorge permettez moi d'évoquer ce médecin
militaire poignardé à mort à marseille
devant ses enfants sans aucun hommage
national alban gervaise mort sans la
france la presse quotidienne régionale
nous informe de ses attaques pour les
seuls derniers jours je cite angers
amiens montpellier loriol-sur-drôme metz
et tant d'autres communes qui ont connu
ces drames ses attaques au couteau
parfois des étrangers déjà connu
défavorablement des services de police
ce qui nous plonge dans
l'incompréhension aussi monsieur le
ministre pouvez vous nous dire si ces
attaques aux personnes dont des
policiers correspondent à un sentiment
d'insécurité au pas et que comptez vous
faire pour y remédier
[Applaudissements]
pour revendre la parole et au ministre
de l'intérieur et des outre-mer où
monsieur d'ahmad un
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les sénateurs la sénatrice vous avez si
je peux me permettre un peu tout
mélanger je vais essayer rapidement
d'évoquer des divers fait que a évoqué
qui sont des drames ont chacun d'entre
eux et je voudrais rendre hommage au
policier qui est effectivement à lyon on
pensait à une interpellation puisque
dans ce quartier de vraie reconquête
républicaine puisque nous y avons mis
trente et un policier spécifique depuis
le 1er janvier dans ce quartier la
guillotière 4 75 interpellations 240% de
garde à vue et de trafiquants arrêtés
depuis le 1er janvier ils ont en civil
fait honneur à leur uniforme si j'ose
dire en intervenant et c'est pour ça
qu'ils opération de police sont
commandés tous les jours pour que
effectivement ce soit lors de la
république et celle des policiers qui
règne dans ce quartier qui vous le savez
depuis 30 ans connaît des difficultés
extrêmement fortes comme d'autres
quartiers de la république vous évoquez
des étrangers en situation régulière ou
irrégulière qui serait capable
effectivement de commettre des actes
délictuels ou criminels je me suis je
crois exprimé extrêmement clairement sur
ce point je veux aussi souligner que
depuis deux ans nous avons expulsé trois
mille étrangers délinquants et nous
allons continuer à le faire et j'espère
que le parlement nous y aidera je veux
simplement souligné que dans la sphère
malheureuse est terrible danger se
réfugier qui a commis ces actes puisque
manifestement il n'y a pas de doute
n'était pas connu des services de police
et qu'il ne faut pas ici tout mélanger
je crois dans une assemblée sérieuse
mais le ministre je ne crois pas que
lorsque les personnes sont attaquées de
la sorte elles ressentent un mélange
elles sont simplement attaqué et leurs
vies sont brisées
mais je croyais que vous étiez ministre
les années précédentes et j'ai dû me
tromper car non seulement vous semblez
découvrir les faits mais vous reprenez
aujourd'hui une partie des réponses et
des propositions pardon que nous avions
formulées pourtant elles ont été
rejetées elles ont été rejeté avec
mépris sous le quinquennat hollande et
macro récemment les peines planchers
pour ceux qui attaquent nos forces de
l'ordre rejetée les places de prison
supplémentaires nous attendons encore
l'expulsion des étrangers qui
représentent une menace rejeté aussi
vous citer tout à l'heure des chiffres
mais ces chiffres sont largement
insuffisants et les propositions que
nous avions faites vous les avez tous
méprisé aujourd'hui c'est en moyenne 120
attaques à l'armé blanche selon
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance et des réponses pénales
observatoire qui a malheureusement été
supprimés alors que ces attaques étaient
souvent à l'époque liées au terrorisme
islamique elles sont aujourd'hui
reléguées à la rubrique faits divers et
vous prononcez toujours les mêmes mots
vous nous dites que nous mélangeons où
vous dites que ce sont des risques des
déséquilibres et des actes isolés ce qui
est un déni de la réalité
vous considérez souvent nos questions
comme illégitimes ou les qualifier même
de nauséabonde et nous ferions la
récupération politique monsieur le
ministre je voudrais vous dire que les
tweets ne remplace pas l'action et
combien de vies blessés perdu ou abîmés
sont aujourd'hui perdus ou abîmés parce
que vous n'avez pas repris nos
propositions merci la parole est qu à
notre collègue angèle préville pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le métier
de professeur est un beau métier noble
et généreux le plus beau métier du monde
paraît-il fleuri ces jours ci des offres
d'emploi du style recherche professeur
18h
936 euros par mois quel choc qu'est-ce
qui s'est défait lentement
insidieusement pour qu'on en arrive là
de quoi est ce le nom s'il ya urgence
4000 postes non pourvus faute de
candidats
je ne comprends ni la méthode du job
dating ni l'offre de le salaire
proprement hallucinante et surtout quel
manque d'anticipation les personnes
recrutées lors de ces jobs dating seront
demain devant vos enfants et petits
enfants mes chers collègues sans
formation plongé dans le bain
bouillonnant des classes au hasard dans
une statistique inconnue est aléatoire
les enfants de la république mérite
mieux enseigner est non seulement une
vocation mais surtout un métier qui ne
s'improvise pas enseigner nécessite et
des qualités personnelles indispensable
et une formation solide c'est un constat
amer le métier de professeur n'est plus
attractif en cause
le salaire très insuffisant le chantier
pour reconstruire la maison éducation
nationale est colossal c'est une
nécessité absolue car en plus nous
sommes très mal classés à l' ocde de
mauvais élève en somme être civilisé
n'est ce pas assurer l'accès au savoir
et à la connaissance et permettre à tous
les enfants de france comme vous l'avez
été monsieur le ministre de devenir ce
qu'ils doivent être il y as parmi les
étudiants pauvres des vocations qui ne
se réalise pas or il existait par le
passé des formations rémunérées pour les
étudiants qui s'engageait dans
l'éducation nationale l'école normale
pour les instituteurs et les instituts
ipes pour les professeurs du second
degré ne serait ce pas là une manière de
combattre les assignations de naissance
tout en résolvant une partie du problème
de recrutement des professeurs
quant aux salaires monsieur le ministre
que proposez vous
pour vous répondre la parole et ministre
de l'éducation nationale du rwanda vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
madame la sénatrice préville la
prochaine rentrée en intervient en effet
dans un contexte délicat de recrutement
des professeurs en raison d'une baisse
d'attractivité structurel de certains
concours de recrutement des enseignants
relevé d'ailleurs récemment dans un
rapport très informés du sénateur
longuet nous sommes cette année
confrontée à une situation un peu
particulière en raison tout d'abord de
la réforme engagée concernant la réforme
concernant le recrutement des
enseignants le passage de bac + 4 à bac
+ 5 à quoi s'ajoute en effet l'existence
d'un marché de l'emploi très tendu qui
rend les recrutements difficiles au
regard de cette situation le ministère a
mis en place une série de mesures pour
assurer les meilleures conditions de
rentrée possible avec des recrutements
sur liste complémentaire
avec des concours supplémentaires et
enfin avec des recrutements
d'enseignants contractuels qui ne se
font pas du tout en quelques instants et
selon les termes que vous avez des
crimes comme la sénatrice l'objectif est
bien que tous les élèves soit accueilli
et bénéficie d'un professeur devant
chaque classe
sachez madame également que toutes les
académies sont mobilisés dès à présent
qu'une cellule de rentrée sera active
dès le 22 août dans chaque rectorat pour
prévenir et résoudre les dernières
difficultés enfin conformément aux
engagements du président de la
république et de la première ministre la
revalorisation à venir dans le cadre du
pacte avec les enseignants fera l'objet
d'une concertation pour renforcer
l'attractivité des métiers de
l'enseignement mieux reconnaître
l'engagement de chacune et chacun des
professeurs est aussi repenser finement
les dynamiques et les évolutions de
carrière
quelques secondes madame préville oui
merci monsieur le ministre vous n'avez
pas répondu sur la proposition qui était
que je vous ai fait de revenir à des
des possibilités qui était ouverte avant
aux étudiants de s'engager dans
l'éducation nationale en étant rémunéré
ce que ce qui permettrait comme je l'aï
dit tout à l'heure de résoudre en partie
la problématique du recrutement des
enseignants
merci la parole et l autre collègue
philippe dominati pour le groupe les
républiques l'oeil
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur jeudi dernier vous avez
installer le nouveau préfet de police
malheureusement pour moi c'est le
treizième préfet de police depuis que je
suis élu parisien vous avez défini un
ordre de mission précis très complet
mais c'est en même temps un bilan des
insuffisances de l'institution et des
déficiences de la sécurité apparaît
divers gouvernements sous la vème
république il s'agit bien évidemment pas
de critiquer les hommes femmes qui
essaient de faire leur devoir mais
divers gouvernements sous la vème
république ont essayé de mettre des
préfets de police que ce soit en corse à
grenoble à lyon est actuellement il y en
a 1 marseille lorsque laurent nu neige
actuel préfet de police de paris a été
nommé à marseille il m'avait expliqué le
côté opérationnel de la préfecture de
police de marseille qui n'aide pas
engoncé dans l'administration la
bureaucratie est en réalité en cela il
partageait l'avis du directeur général
de la police de l'époque éric morvan il
vient d'ailleurs été nommé ministre par
le président macron pour redéfinir les
missions de la préfecture de police ma
question monsieur le ministre est de
savoir si c'est le marseillais où le
parisien qui bénéficient du meilleur
système de sécurité
pour vous répondre la parole le
communiste de l'intérieur les outre-mer
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs j'espère que
j'ai au moins une demi heure pour
répondre à monsieur le sénateur dominati
qui connaît bien le sujet puisqu'il est
là il a quand il a il a rappelé son
expérience parisienne et son expérience
politique bien bien supérieur évidemment
à la mienne mais je veux d'abord rendre
hommage au travail du préfet d'allemands
qui pendant trois ans a dirigé la
préfecture de police dans des conditions
de théorise le et de contestation bien
difficile
j'ai effectivement monsieur le sénateur
dominati installé monsieur le nouveau
préfet de police
avec une feuille de route claire à la
lutte contre la délinquance à paris
peut-être que l'ordre public a été trop
mis en avant dans des circonstances que
devront d'ailleurs tout à fait
comprendre mais la délinquance à paris
augmente et il ya désormais dans le
xviiie dans le 19ème dans le 20e
arrondissement plus de violence urbaine
qu'en seine-saint-denis daté du 14
juillet dernier ce qui pose des
problèmes sans doute pas simplement de
politique de sécurité autres pays mais
de l'agglomération parisienne et de
paris elle-même le deuxième sujet est
évidemment la préparation des jeux
olympiques
là il s'agit pas de payer d
impréparation eu des difficultés mais de
regarder l'avenir et le rendu des zorra
avec la préfecture de police et ses 43
mille agents dont je veux ici renouveler
la confiance du gouvernement un travail
très important pour ce faire alors vous
demander qu'est-ce qu'elle plus efficace
paris n'est pas marseille ça ne vous
aura pas échappé il ya marseille dans
une police municipale il ya marseille un
maire qui a la compétence des caméras de
vidéoprotection et il n'y a pas à
marseille l'immense majorité des lieux
de pouvoir des lieux économique
de circulation qui fait que à paris vous
savez c'est une ville historiquement et
politiquement différente des autres
faut-il évoluer dans la réforme de la
préfecture de police en lien avec la
direction générale la police nationale
sans doute il me semble qu'à première
vue monsieur le sénateur ce n'est pas
l'objectif du préfet de police nous vous
en sommes et qui doit lutter contre la
délinquance et préparer les jo mais
demain dans le cadre du grand pas du
grand paris de la métropole parisienne
et de la question le maire général de
paris dans les institutions sans doute
que la préfecture de police devrait
évoluer évoluer pardon au moins autant
que la ville de paris la métropole est
le grand paris lui-même
dessous de lui des petits
pains celle mini jeux vous l'avez évoqué
tous les forces politiques parisiennes
ont dû créer une police municipale alors
qu'elles n'y étaient pas favorables
nécessairement vous avez été renouvelé
dans votre poste donc vous semblez avoir
l'écouté du président de la république
madame la première ministre a exercé des
fonctions importantes que ce soit dans
l'urbanisme les transports sur la région
parisienne en le président de la
république est le seul président de la
vème république qui a jamais défini les
enjeux de l'île de france qui n'a jamais
s'est jamais intéressé aux structures
institutionnelles de l'île de france le
grand paris ne correspond pas au
périmètre de la préfecture de police
vous parlez de la préparation des jeux
olympiques
en réalité comme vous nous souhaitons
que les parisiens soient en sécurité
surtout et visiteurs qui vont venir nous
voir pour paris les jeux olympiques
juger de votre influence avec madame le
premier ministre pour inciter le
président à s'intéresser à paris
mais si la parole est à notre collègue
pierre autrefois de lévis pour le groupe
de l'union centriste
avait la parole
monsieur le président
madame le premier ministe mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'agriculture et dassault et
nt1 alimentaire monsieur le ministre les
bouleversements engendrés par le
réchauffement climatique ont de lourdes
répercussions sur nos vies on ne compte
plus les vague caniculaire qui
s'abattent sur nos territoires toujours
plus précoces toujours plus fréquente
toujours plus intense le 25 juillet nous
apprenions que la quasi totalité des
départements de france étaient concernés
par des restrictions d'utilisation de
l'eau
90 le sont aujourd'hui en clair la
sécheresse est là de plus avec la hausse
massive des températures le phénomène
d'évapotranspiration des plantes
augmente et le bilan hydrique des sols
est devenu alarmant l'eau est un enjeu
majeur pour le monde agricole sans
mobilisation des pouvoirs publics
c'est notre agriculture tout entière qui
est menacée
or face à ce fléau nos agriculteurs se
sentent abandonnés leur situation est
déjà très difficile il est de notre
devoir de les continuer à les aider il
nous faut absolument développer nos
efforts pour capter l'eau
vous le savez monsieur le ministre le
problème ce n'est pas l'eau mais sa
captation et sa gestion tout au long de
l'année l' agence de l'eau adour garonne
prévoit même que le volume de plus
annuel sera plus importants d'ici 2050
qu'aujourd'hui
des solutions existent
tels que les retenues collinaires ou des
barrages mais elles sont difficiles à
mettre en oeuvre les normes bloc et le
décourage toute initiative dans ce sens
vous allez peut-être me répondre que le
problème c'est l'europe mais alors
pourquoi avec deux fois moins de
ressources en eau que la france
l'espagne arrive à en capter presque dix
fois plus pour y arriver il faut du
volontarisme et du courage politique or
l'état on a souvent manqué ces dernières
années l'abandon du barrage de sivens en
est un exemple caractéristique
aussi monsieur le ministre pouvez vous
nous indiquer concrètement les mesures
que le gouvernement compte mettre en
place pour aider le monde agricole à
faire face aux épisodes de sécheresse je
vous remercie pour vos réponses la
parole tout ministre de l'agriculture et
de souveraineté alimentaire monsieur
marc fesneau avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur pierre antoine lévy vous l'avez
souligné le réchauffement climatique ray
bouleverse la réalité quotidienne il
ouvert son corps plus les réalités
quotidiennes de nos agriculteurs tentent
ils touchent leur culture qui évidemment
leur cheptel vous le savez aussi bien
que moi vous avez bien décrit d'ailleurs
le constat précis que vous avez dans
votre département mais malheureusement
pour elle et tendre de nombreux
départements de france puisque comme
vous l'avez dit l'immense majorité des
départements sont désormais touchés
d'abord les décisions d'urgence et de
gestion de crise que nous devons prendre
jeudi avant de répondre plus précisément
encore votre question des mesures
d'abord de régulation des usages de
l'eau des mesures d' aide au coût de
l'alimentation animale des mesures de
prévention des risques d'incendié existe
et si et si et malheureusement aux
cultures et puis nous avons des besoins
aussi qu'ils sont identifiés en termes
de trésorerie depuis qu'un certain
nombre des leurs on devrait avoir besoin
d'acheter de l'alimentation dès à
présent on est en train d'y travailler
pour essayer de trouver des solutions en
vain malheureusement j'allais dire les
dispositifs classiques que nous
connaissons qui seront à activer le cas
échéant dès lors qu'ils seront bien
identifiés on voit bien qu'on y va tous
directement mis hors de cette gestion de
crise nous avons besoin de raisonner sur
le plus long terme vous avez raison et
de raisonner sur la gestion de l'eau
d'abord l'innovation au travers du plan
france relance qui se termine mais qui a
permis de nous déployer en direction de
l'agriculture plus de 600 millions
d'euros pour acquérir des équipements
qui permettent de mieux répondre à ses
exigences de gestion de l'eau ypres en
particulier d'irrigation deuxièmement le
travail qui est fait c'est l'accès à
l'eau c'est la nécessité de rendre plus
facile l'accès à l'eau et cette issue
des travaux du varennes de l'eau je ne
parle pas du système assurantiel qui va
se déployer mais les travaux issus du
varennes de l'eau aussi dridi l'accès à
l'eau les textes encadrant les volumes
d'eau prélevables c'est un décret qui
était attendu par les professionnels
nous y travaillons et christophe béchu
qui sera produit dans les prochains
jours ça permettra de dire la ressource
qui sera palpable la deuxième question
essentielle c'est de créer des retenues
collinaires des retenues d'eau qui
permettent de faire face au fond à la
dérégulation pluviométrique qui répond à
la dérégulation à la régulation et
dérégulation pardon climatique et donc
nous devons travailler il ya besoin
d'accélérer et donc avec le ministre
mais chez nous travaillerons pour
territoire par territoire voir les
projets qui sont prêts pour qu'il laisse
pour qu'ils se développent et là où il
ya des blocages que nous puissions lever
les contraintes administratives parfois
de temporalité parfois juridique pour
avancer plus rapidement c'est bien ce
qui est prévu par le gouvernement
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
à d'autres collègues jean sol pour le
groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre les nuisances et
des gâteaux gaccio occasionner de façon
récurrente par les communautés des gens
du voyage qui investissent certains
terrains de nos communes en toute
illégalité préoccupe de plus en plus nos
élus en effet les procédures d'expulsion
lorsqu'elles sont engagés dans deux
êtres mises en oeuvre et se révèlent
inefficaces de tels retards ont des
conséquences environnementales
économiques et sanitaires extrêmement
dommageable
dégradation et pollution des espaces
dont les zones natura 2000 et sniffe vol
et gaspillage d'eau raccordement
électrique illégaux et précaires sur
plus de volume de déchets à gérer à la
charge des communes atteinte à l'image
et l'attractivité de nos territoires
délinquance itinérante
aujourd'hui les collectivités pourtant
en conformité avec le schéma
départemental d'accueil des gens du
voyage
subissez des occupations illicites
récurrente sans que l'état qui en a le
pouvoir ne parviennent pourtant pas à
les interrompre et à les évacuer
rapidement il nous semble donc
nécessaire de réformer les modalités
d'accueil d'évacuation des gens du
voyage sans les stigmatiser
en créant notamment une procédure
d'expulsion d'urgence facilitant
l'enlèvement et la saisie rapide de
leurs véhicules procédure que les maires
pourraient activer en cas d'occupation
illicite et ce quelle que soit la nature
du terrain
ma question est donc la suivante face au
désarroi de nos administrés dans nos
élus et de nos forces de l'ordre et
avant qu'un drame ne se produise
qu'envisage idées à cambridge il veut
vous de faire pardon monsieur le
ministre il ya urgence pour nous
répondre
mais mis à part hall et au ministre de
l'intérieur d outre-mer monsieur bart
menacé le président des messieurs c'est
un monsieur sénateur vous avez
parfaitement raison c'est une
multiplication de faits singulièrement
cet été d'ailleurs qui remonte de la
part des élus de la république et des
préfets ayant eu à connaître à créer une
aire d'accueil des gens du voyage et à
connaître les difficultés vous évoquez
temps sur les terrains publics sur les
terrains privés mais c'est parfois la
même chose pour les citoyens je
comprends les difficultés forte que vous
évoquez et les nuisances extrêmement
puissante que vous soulignez je veux
quand même cependant dire que même s'il
existe des nuisances lorsque les
communes ou les départements ont fait
les schémas prévu par la loi besson et
la loi besson de il y a encore quand
même beaucoup de schémas intercommunaux
de schémas départementaux qui ne sont
pas complets et je veux dire ici devant
la chambre du sénat que l'état aide 45
projets d'aires d'accueil de jeunes
ménages ont été fait l'année dernière et
ont été très large ans une ancienne
d'ailleurs par l'état nous avons créé
une amende forfaitaire délictuelle qui
est en expérimentation et nous allons
généraliser avec le garde des sceaux qui
permet justement de limiter les
procédures et pour les policiers les
gendarmes ne mette une amende de
quelques milliers d'euros par caravane
dans le cas où ces caravanes ou ses
mobiles ne sont pas légalement sur un
territoire cette expérimentation sera
généralisé permettra comme une asd comme
nous avons fait sur les stupéfiants de
pouvoir être plus efficaces que les
procédures cependant il ya sans doute
encore beaucoup de lourdeur dans les
procédures judiciaires et dans les
procédures administratives pour ce qui
est du judiciaire je laisserais
évidemment le garde des sceaux vous
répondons ce qui le concerne je suis
tout à fait ouvert par les travaux du
sénat dans le cadre des textes de lois
que j'aurais à présenter devant votre
assemblée d'améliorer évidemment le
processus qui permet à un préfet qu'il
est le premier je crois avec les élus à
subir ces difficultés pour que nous
puissions avoir moins de paperasse moins
de recours - difficulté entendre et
écouter bien sûr des gens du voyage mais
qu'ils respectent les règles de la
république et chacune de nos communes
monsieur sol
monsieur le ministre nos communes ne
doivent plus souffrir à cause d'une
minorité qui ne respectent pas les lois
de la république mais néanmoins ce face
à ce contexte aussi tendu que je
décrivais et en référence aux propos de
madame la première ministre elisabeth
bornes
qualifiant le sénat de chambre
d'apaisement et d'équilibré je vous
invite monsieur le ministre à soutenir
la proposition de loi de mes collègues
patrick chaize s'il vient de noël et
alain chatillon voter ici même et visant
à consolider les outils juridiques
juridique permettant aux maires de
mettre fin aux occupations illégales des
gens du voyage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
martine filleul pour le groupe
socialiste que le juste que régulière
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre en allemagne pour lutter contre
l'inflation et la pollution les trains
sont illimitées pour 9 euros par mois
pendant l'été l'espagne va rendre
gratuites certaines liaisons
ferroviaires et genève lance une
initiative pour la gratuité en france
rien nous sommes sur le banc des mauvais
élèves malgré un afflux dainville 4
millions de billets longue distance
vendu seulement pour juillet août
malgré une inflation qui précarisent les
français les billets de trains
continuent à grimper avec une
augmentation de 14,9 pour cent en juin
et aucune amélioration perspectives pour
2023 le groupe socialiste vous propose
pourtant depuis plusieurs années une tva
à 5 5% et l'augmentation des moyens de
la sncf c'est d'ailleurs le sens de la
proposition de loi que nous portons
voulait refusé pourtant la planète a
besoin de plus de trains les citoyens
ont besoin de prix plus bas la sncf a
besoin de plus d'argent et vous monsieur
le ministre vous reporter la faute sur
les français ou les invités à réserver
leurs billets on avance avec des cartes
de réduction en choisissant les horaires
moins coûteux insinuer ainsi que les
citoyens achètent volontairement les
billets les plus chers témoigne de votre
des connexions et de votre
incompréhension des difficultés des
français
monsieur le ministre que comptez vous
faire pour permettre à tous nos
concitoyens de prendre le train
ces prochains mois à des tarifs
abordables
pour vous répondre la parole et mobilise
délégué en charge des transports
monsieur clément bonne vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
martine filleul l'européen que je suis m
effectuer des comparaisons mais il faut
dire la vérité complète qui est menée en
allemagne c'est une expérimentation avec
des billets de train en effet à 9 euros
pour le seul été
22 à partir du 31 août
à partir du 31 août cela s'arrêtera je
rappelle que le coût pour la
collectivité partagée d'ailleurs avec
les länder allemands donc avec
l'équivalent des régions françaises est
de 3 milliards d'euros je pense que nous
devons examiner les suites tarification
mais nous devons dire ce qui est notre
priorité la plus claire je ne suis pas
sûr que le seul sujet que nous devions
traiter soit les pics tarifaires pendant
quelques week end de vacances même si
cela est extrêmement important est que
nous remettrons à plat ce sujet aussi
avec la sncf il y a déjà des mesures qui
ont été prises je pense en effet aux
cartes de tarification qui permettent le
plafonnement des prix ça n'est pas une
réponse sans doute parfaite ou complète
mais c'est un propos un projet important
ça la priorité le réinvestissement
massif que nous avons fait ces dernières
années portent avec beaucoup de
collectivités d'ailleurs dans le train
le transport du quotidien et je crois
que si nous devons avoir une priorité en
matière budgétaire en particulier nous
aurons l'occasion d'en discuter dans les
prochaines semaines elle porte sur les
transports de petites lignes sur les
trains du quotidien que nous avons dans
nos grandes aires métropolitaines sur le
la régénération la modernisation de
notre réseau ou là nous avons un retard
en effet très important sur nos
partenaires européens nous l'avons
investi plus de moyens beaucoup plus de
moyens ces dernières années multiplié
par 4 l'investissement en dix ans et
notamment ces cinq dernières années sur
la junte la régénération du réseau dont
bien sûr les suites tarification sont
importants je ne veux pas laisser quoi
le sait croire pardon que le sujet se
résume au tgv et à la question des
vacances et la rentrée scolaire qui se
prépare ce sont les transports du
quotidien c'est le travail je rappelle
que le reste à charge pour les usagers
c'est le travail de l'état de la sncf
que beaucoup d'opérateurs des
collectivités c'est un quart du coût
total des transports publics c'est le
plus faible reste à charge d'europe sont
c'est là dessus que nous devons mettre
je crois collectivement l'effort
budgétaire politiques territoriales dans
les prochains mois mais mme filleul
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président c'est un
fait monsieur le ministre tout ce que
vous avez pu me mettre en oeuvre n'a
visiblement pas eu de conséquence sur le
prix des billets est donc sur le pouvoir
d'achat des français
la parole est et à notre collègue
laurence muller brawn pour le groupe
l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le
gouvernement a mis en place depuis
novembre 2000 21 un bouclier tarifaire
afin de contenir la hausse des prix de
l'électricité et du gaz à 4% en effet
les coûts de l'énergie explose et les
français doivent pouvoir continuer à
payer leurs factures
c'est une mesure qui est à saluer
puisque sans elle les prix auraient
augmenté de 45% mais nous sommes
interpellés par le cas particulier des
résidents d pad et en maison de retraite
qui sont exclus du dispositif
tout comme les entreprises et les
collectivités
leur situation est pourtant identique à
celle de l'ensemble des particuliers
puisqu'ils sont bien dans un lieu
d'habitation qui repose sur un contrat
de prestations à durée indéterminée dans
lequel figurent aussi la fourniture
d'énergie d'ailleurs le fait que
certains résidents des ehpad soit
éligible au chèque énergie et aux apl
confirme qu'il s'agit bien de leur
domicile j'ai pu comparer les chiffres
avec les directeurs des ehpad de mon
canton et nous avons pu constater que le
résident paye deux fois plus cher leur
électricité que tous les autres
habitants dans ma commune de gerstheim à
l'ehpad des calculs prévisionnels montre
que l'augmentation pourra atteindre
jusqu'à
460 9% pour les heures plein hiver sans
compter les taxes cette différence de
traitement ne se justifie pas entre un
habitant et son voisin
nous n'avons aucune explication crédible
à donner aux familles il s'agit bien là
d'un oubli qui génère une inégalité
qu'il faut corriger avant l'automne
que proposez vous monsieur le ministre
pour ne pas pénaliser nos aînés les plus
fragiles dont vous répondre la parole
est au ministre des solidarités de
l'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
monsieur jean christophe combes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice muller brawn vous avez raison
les coûts de l'énergie aujourd'hui
connaissent une augmentation extrêmement
importante du fait de la conjoncture
internationale et je crois que la france
a pris très tôt des mesures
exceptionnelles est importante pour
protéger les français de cette inflation
vous avez raison aussi quand vous dites
que le prix le tarif d'hébergement en
ehpad inclut le coût de l'énergie
néanmoins je voudrais rassurer
immédiatement l'ensemble des résidents
et de leurs familles des résidents
d'ehpad et de leurs familles qui sont
inquiets de l'augmentation de ses coûts
puisque les tarifs d'hébergement sont
encadrés quel que soit votre situation
que vous soyez et que vous bénéficiez
d'une place habilité à l'aide sociale
auquel cas le tarif est encadrée dans le
cadre d'une négociation entre le
département et l'ehpad où que vous soyez
dans un ehpad en général privé
commercial où le tarif est effectivement
fixé librement par l'opérateur à
l'entrée de du résident dans l'ehpad
mais néanmoins encadré dans son
évolution par un tarif qui est fixé
chaque année au niveau national donc ces
mesures permettent normalement
d'encadrer l'évolution des tarifs en
ehpad alors on regardera précisément la
situation que vous dénoncez mais je la
trouve étonnante au regard du du système
et enfin je voudrais également signalé
l'effort extrêmement important du
gouvernement pour dans le cadre du ségur
de la santé améliorer la performance
énergétique de nos établissements et 1,5
milliard d'euros qui ont été mis sur la
table pour investir dans les ehpad sont
conditionnés à l'amélioration de la
performance énergétique de ces
établissements et les directeurs
d'établissements sont aujourd'hui
accompagnés par des conseillers en
performance énergétique pour améliorer
la performance énergétique des ehpad au
quotidien
madame muller brawn
monsieur le ministre les tarifs peuvent
être encadrées mais quelqu'un doit bien
payé or les départements aujourd'hui ne
peuvent pas faire face à cette explosion
des tarifs énergétiques les les chiffres
sont bien concret est prêt vise et on ne
peut plus vous savez que quelques 700
mille personnes vivent en ehpad est on
ne peut plus charger la barque le prix
d'un mois en ehpad est suffisamment
élevé pour les familles merci merci la
parole est à
madame françoise gatel pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la première ministre monsieur le
ministre si vous avez aimé la question
de mathieu darnaud je ne doute pas que
vous allez aimer la mienne
puisque dans notre pays et je suis
sérieuse si tourmenté seule l'efficacité
de l'action publique nous permettra
collectivement de regagner la confiance
de nos concitoyens et vous le savez les
collectivités aux côtés de l'état en
sont des acteurs essentiels par temps
calme comme par gros temps mais pour ce
faire monsieur le ministre l ont besoin
de stabilité
d'anticipation et donc d'un cap au cours
des débats sur la loi de finances
rectificative monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances a inventé de
manière spontanée
le concept de task force est ainsi qu il
appelait j'irai force de concertation
pour gérer l'atterrissage hasardeuse
d'amendements que je qualifierais
d'accidents tolède et qu'il propose de
prolonger jusqu'à la loi de finances
aujourd'hui spontanée et curative si je
puis dire cette initiative
deviendra-t-elle préventif sera t-elle
élargi aux associations d'élus au sénat
comme une parfaite concrétisation du
discours de la méthode de madame la
première ministre monsieur le ministre
profiterez-vous du silence législatives
de l'été pour échanger sur un projet de
loi de finances 2010 23
sécurisée parce qu inscrit dans une
trajectoire pluriannuelle en ayant
traiter les questions qui fâchent cva
inflation fonction dépenses imposées aux
collectivités merci monsieur miné
par les communistes de la transition
écologique de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur béchu
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la première ministre madame la
présidente gatel
nous avons une chef et elle a défini un
cap ici à la tribune du sénat à
l'occasion de sa déclaration de
politique générale et ce cap c'est celui
de la co-construction le 19 juillet
quand j'ai reçu l'ensemble des
associations d'élus
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire que nous
mettrions à profit à la rentrée un temps
pour travailler ensemble avec le sénat
notamment avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires pour être en capacité de
co-construire les textes qui nous
attendent sur les sujets que vous avez
évoqué avec les balises que j'ai eu
l'occasion de rappeler que le sénateur
d'arnaud a parfaitement
retenu notamment sur l'absence de baisse
des dotations des collectivités
territoriales l'absence totale de
ponction pour que les choses soient
dites de manière encore plus clair nous
allons non seulement pouvoir profiter de
l'été mais compte tenu du fait que la
séance ne reprendra qu'au début du mois
d'octobre la méthode qui a été annoncé
ici sa compagne des délais et du temps
pour être capable de le faire et les
sujets ne manquent pas c'est vrai sur le
plan financier je n'oublie pas les
interpellations que j'ai eu sur le zéro
artificialisation net
je ne voulais pas la question qui
concerne la cotisation sur la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises et les méthodes
pour assurer la compensation est donc je
nous souhaite collectivement de prendre
quelques heureux quelques ressources
pour nous retrouver dès la fin du mois
d'août de manière active pour avancer
sur tous ces sujets
madame gatel
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le ministre alors quitte
à m'attirer les foudres de mes collègues
je salue votre chef et sa méthode je
salue aussi le mien qui nous invite
collectivement est dans l'anticipation
l'exigence et la construction
sérieusement monsieur le ministre les
collectivités peuvent pas vivre au
rythme de convulsions budgétaires elles
ont l obligation d'avoir des budgets en
équilibre donc anticipo fixons nous un
câble nous serons rendez vous merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue esther
benbassa sap pour la réunion
administrative dessinateur ne figurant
sur la liste d'oka groupe vous avez la
parole
chers collègues
si les pouvoirs publics font des efforts
depuis la grande canicule de 2003 pour
lancer des campagnes de prévention
pendant les pics de chaleur le système
pénitentielle doivent faire face seule à
la crise les détenus se débrouiller avec
le peu de moyens à leur disposition
ceci alors même que la surpopulation
carcérale atteint les sommets depuis
janvier 2022 j'ai visité sept puisons à
travers la france le mardi 19 19 juillet
jour de canicule je me suis rendu avec
mon équipe nous le présente entente de
l'oip un journaliste de l afp à la
maison d'arrêt de nanterre laquelle est
elle aussi occupée environ 1 150 % est
confronté aux mêmes problèmes de vétusté
d'insalubrité de promiscuité de manque
d'hygiène seulement trois douches par
semaine
possède un ventilateur qui peut se
l'acheter même avec un ventilateur un
drame houllier accroché aux barreaux il
faisait 37 à 38 degrés dans les cellules
au dernier étage dans la coursive à ciel
ouvert 45° des détenus répondent de
l'eau par terre et marche pieds nus pour
se rafraîchir
ils parlent de leurs souffrances il
demande un peu d'humanité plus de
douches et moins de surpopulation pour
commencer monsieur le ministre que
compte faire l'état pour rénover nos
prisons et les adapter au réchauffement
climatique
l'enfer ce n'est pas les autres comme
sartre l'écrivait l'enfer c'est la
prison en temps de canicule merci pour
vous répondre la parole et à monsieur le
garde des sceaux me la justice monsieur
eric dupond moretti monsieur monsieur
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice benbassa 1 comment
vous dire depuis que la prison existe je
pense le retour des beaux jours en la
détention plus difficile et c'est encore
pire lorsque la canicule vient s'ajouter
à cela c'est vrai pour les personnels
pénitentiaires que je ne veux pas
oublier troisième force de sécurité de
notre pays
c'est vrai aussi pour les détenus que
personne n'oublie et le sénat d'ailleurs
a voté à l'unanimité le texte qui avait
été proposé par monsieur le président de
la commission des lois du sénat qui je
rends hommage moi aussi c'est mon quart
d'heure de fayotage c'est le texte sur
les conditions indignes alors sur le
plan national nous rénovons des prisons
130 millions d'euros ont été consacrés à
la rénovation d'établissements
pénitentiaires soit le double de ce qui
était fait précédemment
je pense aux baumettes je pense à
fresnes je pense à fleury mérogis je
pense à la santé sur le plan national
contrairement à ce que l'on a pu dire
tout à l'heure nous construisons des
prisons et nous en aurons construit
49 15000 place nette à la fin du
quinquennat en ce qui concerne nanterre
en ce qui concerne nanterre je vous
donnais 4 préconisations fortes qui ont
été légitimement porté par
l'administration pénitentiaire
d'abord mes deux seins
plus de médecins pour ceux qui sont en
situation de fragilité je pense aux
détenus âgés ensuite rafraîchissement
des locaux
avec diverses solutions
ensuite remplacement des frigos 40-50
été
envoyée la semaine dernière et mis en
place et enfin davantage de douche que
ce que prévoit la réglementation
la prison on le sait elle est faite pour
punir elle est faite pour mettre à
l'abri un individu dangereux de la
société elle est faite également pour
réinsérer il faut naturellement de la
fermeté bien sûr sans démagogie et de
l'humanisme sans angélisme
merci
merci monsieur le ministre mais il faut
quand même faire quelque chose on voit
que ce n'est pas suffisant il faut
construire pas plus de prison il faut
les construire autrement incarcéré
autrement vous me conseillez quand même
que le système pénitentiaire
requiert des réformes encore plus de
réformes merci
merci
mes chers collègues en application du
cinquième alinéa de l'article 13 de la
constitution
ainsi que de la loi organique et des
lois ordinaires du 23 juillet 2010
prises pour son application la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable a
émis lors de sa réunion de ce jour un
avis favorable par 27 voix pour aucune
voix contre
à la nomination de monsieur jean castex
la présidence du conseil d'ami passion
de l' agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport en france
à faire pâlir d'envié
je
vous rappelle que les prochaines
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
auront lieu le mercredi 5 octobre
oui 2022 je vais nous aurons une séance
de questions orales la semaine prochaine
je le rappelle je vais lever la séance
elle sera reprise de jeudi 28 juillet à
10h30 pour l'examen du projet de loi
portant mesures d'urgence pour la
protection du pouvoir d'achat la séance
est levée